a candlelight vigil was held to honor
two toddlers killed in a suspected DUI
crash earlier today this happened Sunday
near Lone Mountain and Clayton Street in
North Las Vegas Madison Kimbrough spoke
with family and those who live in the
area she joins us live tonight with more
on their message Madison
it was a solemn evening here on Scott
Robinson Boulevard as people gathered
here to honor Taylor and Rosemarie
Wilmer you can look behind me as you can
see the vigil that has been set up in
Memorial as it's grown in size since the
crash took place here last Sunday
qbq is safe
go drink and drive a message from Tavon
Wilmer the father of Taylor and
Rosemarie Wilmer the two toddlers who
were tragically killed Sunday night
after getting into a car accident in
North Las Vegas the children's aunt was
driving and allegedly Under the
Influence when she hit a tree head-on
and the children's mother was riding in
the passenger seat Tavon attended
Saturday night's vigil for the two girls
as family friends and neighbors gathered
lying down flowers candles and stuffed
animals for the toddlers every day I
wake up after I saw him part of the
lesson my kids didn't deserve this
according to North Las Vegas Police
neither of the toddlers were wearing
age-appropriate child safety restraints
at the time parents in the area sharing
their concerns as they say speeding and
reckless driving seems to be all too
frequent on their block and for this
tragedy to happen it's too close to home
it's sad when you come by and you see
that this is in your neighborhood these
people use this street as a cut through
you know and they really don't care you
know I mean and it needed to be some
kind of speed bumps or something to slow
the traffic down in here I was at home I
heard the sirens this is not the first
accident uh it was the first fatal one
that I know but I've seen many other
accidents here so simply because cars
are speeding
the Wilmer family created a cash app
link for those who would like to help
donate funds for the girls burials and
Tavon Sharon with eight news now that he
does not judge the mother of his
children and knows that she loved their
children very much reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now